Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at our respective
tables of varying lighting
in our own homes,
we're gonna be talking
about relational dynamics
during quarantine.
I'm tellin' ya man.
We're gonna open a can of,
well not a can of Whoopass,
I'm talkin' about a can of worms,
that's what I was thinkin' about.
How many cans are there?
Hey, listen, there's worms.
there's Whoopass,
I can open a can of Whoopass.
You want me to come
over and whoop your ass?
I'd like to see you try.
I need to whoop somebody's ass right now.
I'd love to see you
come over here and try.
Talkin' about relational dynamics,
there's a couple times I'm just walking
around my house and I just, I just
Sometimes I hug my kids and it's turned
from an affectionate hug into
how hard can I squeeze them
before they start to panic.
I don't know if that's
a good thing to admit,
but I mean, it's not like Lando's eyes
were bugged out or anything.
My wife was whispering
to me I think.
What are you whisperin' about?
If she's gonna talk, tell her to speak up.
Yeah, see,
this is what happens.
This is a show.
See, this is it.
Shepard's on a call with his teacher
and I'm doing this,
there's tension in the air, man.
I mean that's what quarantine's all about,
it's about tension in the air and
There's Whoopass, there's worms,
and there's what else?
I mean is there another can?
I've opened cans of
knowledge for people before.
Oh gosh.
Give me a break, man.
You know what?
It's expired.
I'm gonna open a can of knowledge on you.
That's not one, nope.
We're still at two, that's not one.
I thought you were gonna say
Well, maybe there should
be one.
a can of beans.
But that's too literal, too literal.
Yeah, sometimes I do go to cans of beans,
I have been tryin' to
do dry beans on my own,
but I do have cans as a backup.
Interesting thing about cans of beans
is that I find myself trying to get
my beans to taste as
good as the canned beans.
It seems that that is the
goal of every bean recipe
is just to taste as good as canned beans
because those people at Busch's, man,
they figured it out.
Dude Prefect is selling their own beans.
When you found out about
that did it make you mad?
Yeah, it was like a
trick shot to the heart.
It made me a little mad.
I was like, "Hold on, we
should be selling beans."
Does this mean we can't sell beans?
I think we should undercut Dude Perfect.
We should...
What's it called when you back in,
when someone goes up for
a rebound and you back
into them and then they fall?
Let's use their terminology.
That's boxing out.
Let's box them out on their own beans.
Let's buy their beans and undercut them.
That's a difficult.
Okay, you're using, you've
got three analogies going now.
I'm on, see, I also have tension and now
look at me, I'm taking
it out on Dude Perfect.
The people on the internet that are like,
the ones that invite the
least amount of ridicule.
All of the sudden I'm picking
a fight with Dude Perfect?
This is what's happening.
I mean, I've been looking
forward to this conversation
because, Rhett, I look
forward to our Ear Biscuit
every week, 'cuz it's one
of a handful of lifelines
that I have and Ear Biscuiteer listening,
if you feel like this show is a lifeline
in this quarantine, don't
put so much pressure on us.
But I'm glad to hear it.
But I'm trying to figure out,
there's another part of
me that I think it could
be therapeutic to get this out,
but I got, there's some
stuff in this past week,
a little bit more that I don't know,
as we start to talk about
relational dynamics in my home,
I just might...
I guess I'm gonna go there.
I think it'll be,
I'd like to verbally process.
You don't have to
Well I think we're about to
open a can of knowledge.
I think we're both
gonna go there.
No, I think we're both gonna go there
and I think
You can open a can of ear.
Okay.
Open a can of listen.
Ear cans, that's just another
name for big headphones.
I think we're both gonna go there,
I think this is about, this
is a little commiseration.
Both with each other, but
also with a mythical beast
and it's interesting
because I see people talk
about, "Oh, it was cool when
you guys talked about movies
"because it was lighthearted."
Or, "When you talked about
hobbies during quarantine,
"it was lighthearted
"and I needed that."
And I'm not saying this is
not gonna be lighthearted,
but we're all processing together.
Yep.
And so it's gonna be what it's gonna be.
Whatever kind of cans
need to be opened up,
Whoopass, knowledge, beans,
what was the other one?
Ear cans.
Cans of listen, cans of listening.
But even before that, worms.
Worms, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
one of the originals,
one of the original cans.
Yeah, that's right.
Now we're gonna spray those cans down
and then we're gonna wipe those cans down
and then we're gonna move
them to a disinfected area,
and then we're gonna proceed to open them,
one by one.
Before we get into talking about,
well actually this is
a relational dynamic,
I mean I think I wanna start by talking
about my relational dynamic
with the most important
member of my family
and that is Barbara.
Of course.
And our relational dynamic
has changed during this time.
Barbara is, first of all I think Barbara
is confused that I'm around so much.
Yeah.
And I think that
I've lost a little of my spark for her.
Oh?
I mean one of the things that I've noticed
is that I mean I hate to admit this,
but it's very true.
My wife is the favorite of Barbara.
In fact, Barbara loves
my wife so much that
she will, the thing that
she's doing right now
is you know how I get down on the floor
every single morning to do
my back stretching routine.
Of course, yes.
And traditionally, that
has been Barbara's cue
to get down on top of me.
She doesn't do that anymore?
That's what she does.
Well now what she does is
when I get on the ground,
now Barbara sleeps at the
foot of the bed most nights.
Barbara stands up, looks at me
and then goes and starts
licking Jessie's face.
So it's like oh, now I need
to go have human contact,
but why jump down there
with that bearded maniac
when I could kiss this clean faced woman?
Have you talked to her about it?
And that's what's happening.
Have I talked to Barbara about it?
Yeah.
Well I begin to beg.
I have a thing that I do,
I start going
Oh Barbara.
And what does she do?
She looks at me and then she begins
to nestle into Jessie even more.
She's afraid.
There she is right there,
she just came over here to look.
She's like, "Yeah, yeah."
You're responding to me right now?
You want some love?
You can't have any.
Jade, come here.
Jade.
I'm having a similar thing with Jade
because if you watched our
Mythical Society Car Vlog,
we do those once a month,
well, before all this happened.
I shared that Jade is
not sleeping in the bed
with me anymore because she would get up
in the middle of the night to drink water
and she would only do
it if she had an escort,
which will be me,
but it would wake up me and Christy,
so and sometimes she would
need to go to the bathroom,
so we started crating her
in order to retrain her
to go all night without food or water,
or peeing, and then just
do it in the morning, Jade.
But then, over this break,
she started sleeping not in
the crate, but with Lincoln.
And I'm really starting to feel jealous
because we're letting
the kids sleep in later,
so it's 10:20 right now.
Lincoln got up like 20 minutes ago,
which meant Jade didn't get
up until 20 minutes ago.
I don't know if she's
peeing in his bed or what.
Naw, he just took her out.
So all that quality time I
used to have with my dog,
I really miss Jade and I
wanna put her back in my bed,
but now Lincoln is starting to say that
he's the favorite.
The dynamics are changing here,
even with the dogs.
Well, and I think it's representative of
larger things that are happening,
but one of the concerning
things that's happening
with Barbara, of course,
Barbara is a small bushy dog.
I don't know if that's the correct term,
technical term,
but she's got a lot of hair.
That's a breed, yeah.
She needs to be groomed.
And she's got some, I
don't remember what she is,
but she's a mut, but she's
got something in her that
she would, her hair would
grow very very long,
like even down to the floor.
Whoa.
But she's got some Poodle
in her, so it's curly,
so I don't know what would happen,
but it would fro out and
it would be very big.
So she gets regularly groomed,
but of course, nothing like that.
I mean, regular grooming
is not happening for me,
as you can see, and also
for anyone in this house,
including Barbara.
Now, I don't care.
Yeah, me too.
And I don't care that
she's got dread locks
and there's other things
happening in her hair
and it's like I was just
like let's let it ride,
you know what I'm saying?
Okay.
And we'll fix this at the end of this.
Gives us something to look forward to,
but Jessie wasn't having it, so she bought
a grooming kit on Amazon.
Like clippers?
Yeah.
And proceeded to begin to shorn our dog
and let me just say, I
think it's worth paying
the groomers to get your dog groomed based
on what Barbara came out looking like.
There's just something about the...
Can you get her?
I wanna see what she looks like.
Well, it was really,
it only lasted for about 48 hours,
it's like now you can't really tell,
but...
It wasn't that short.
She did something with the like...
The groomers, they know
about balance, right?
So you've got, she's got these furry legs
and they're supposed
to maintain their width
as they go down and they
maybe even flare out
a little bit at the end,
but it gives the dog sort of
like it's got sort of like a...
These are things you
don't ever think about
until you do it wrong.
So Jessie went with a tapered jean look,
like an 80's tapered jean look.
Jessie is like watching me
talk about her right now.
She's got some pegs.
She's got the peg pants.
It gave Barbara like a top heaviness
that looked like she was about to tip over
at any time.
Yeah.
And I was like how is this
dog even standing up straight?
It's a hair illusion.
I also realize how shallow I am
because I didn't like
Barbara for about 48 hours,
I was like, "You're not cute anymore."
She knew it too.
The only reason I like you
is because you're so cute.
She knew it man.
Now you know why.
And also in the back
of my mind, yeah,
she's not getting on top of
me in the morning anymore,
so...
The chicken and the egg.
Oh, but one of the things that,
oh, we thought about it at the time
when the grooming was happening,
we're like I think there's
something with the anal gland.
I know they do something
with the anal gland,
but I mean, of course,
we're not gonna do that.
They express it,
that's what they do.
Yeah, they express it.
And I was like of course
we're not gonna go there.
But the other night, we're all
watching television together
and Barbara comes in the room
and we immediately notice
the smell of...
It's like somebody took
one of those bottles
of fish oil that you
Vitamins?
Take for your cardiovascular system
and they left it out in the sun
for like 72 months
and then they brought it inside
and then they opened it up,
that's what it...
And I figured that that
wasn't what had happened.
And so I just said, "Is
that the anal gland?"
It is, yes.
And then Jessie proceeded to grab Barbara
and just slightly lift
her tail for a moment
and she confirmed it was
indeed the anal gland.
Now typically, they'll do the butt scoot
and that's also a sign
that the anal glands
are not properly expressing.
Yeah, and after I went on YouTube...
And looking into this...
Small dogs especially.
Our dogs are not natural,
our dogs are so far from the
just natural canine species
by this point that it comes
with some complications,
including they need humans there
to do things like
express their anal glands
on a regular basis
in a way that large dogs
apparently don't need as much.
And so I um...
Yeah because typically in the wild
'cuz I was curious about this a year ago
and 'cuz I never to Jade to the groomer
and that helped me justify doing it
because I was curious,
but I didn't wanna put my
fingers where my research was,
you know what I'm saying?
But I found out that
like not to get graphic,
but when a dog that's
functioning properly poops,
it expresses the anal gland
is like part of that--
Yeah, so the poop will stink even more.
And I don't care to know exactly why,
it's probably got to do with some sort
of aromal communication,
but it's abhorrent to me,
so I'm done talking about it.
But go ahead.
Well, I'm not because I haven't finished.
So I watched the YouTube
video and it looks so easy.
The woman was like get a pair of gloves
and just sort of put your fingers
on each side of the anus
and you squeeze and
pull at the same time--
10 o' clock and two o' clock?
She showed, I think it's
more like three o' clock
and 9 o' clock, but she said this is what,
she showed on a paper towel or something,
like this is what will come out
and it will smell awful.
Oh ho.
And so we gave Barbara a bath
and I proceeded to put on,
the only gloves I had,
which were dish gloves.
I reached in there,
Barbara seemed
Hold on, before,
before you gave her a bath or after?
Uh, no before.
Okay, good.
Like during.
She was in the sink
getting ready to get wet.
Barbara looked at me like, "Well now."
Yeah, you're pinching her anus.
And but she also didn't
seem to mind too much,
which I guess it was
like oh you also do this.
I've had this done regularly by that lady
at the groomer, but you also do this?
Okay, lots of new things happening.
Familial bonus.
Nothing came out.
And I think what we
concluded at the time was,
"Oh, she must have
already expressed herself.
Earlier, that's what happened when
we were watching television.
Now I said I wasn't gonna talk about it,
but just to interject my experience here,
I was experiencing the same...
Jade was doing the scooting,
I gave her a bath a week ago
and I remembered as I
was giving her a bath,
she's been scooting, I need to try this.
And it just so happens--
You need to try scooting?
Eric, the guy who used to be our friend
who then we fell out of contact with
and then he started texting us
about our Lost Years Podcast.
After that, he sent me
a text and he was like
this is what I'm doing today or something
and then it was like a Wikihow picture
of expressing a dog's anal glands.
Everybody's having to figure this out.
And that image popped into my head
and I thought it was 10 and two,
but that's when you're driver's ed.
And you know what?
I just reached under there and I gave it
as little pinch and I
didn't even have on gloves.
Oh god, why?
Because at sometimes
my nana comes out in me
and my nana, you know my nana,
she's like sometimes she doesn't care.
She'll walk around naked or she'll like
she'll do the walking farts
and she doesn't apologize for anything.
When she taught me how to blow bubbles--
What does that have to do with touching
your dog's butt without a glove.
She would chew up the gum,
poke her tongue through it
and then take it out of
her mouth and then put
that slot where her
tongue was, over my tongue
and then tell me to blow and that's
how I learned to blow bubbles.
She grew up on the farm.
She doesn't care about stuff like this.
You touch a dog's anus.
And then you're washing the dog,
just immediately wash your hand
and I just did that.
And I know that seems
out of character for me,
but I'm like screw it, we're in wash mode,
let's go for it.
Hold up, but did anything come out?
I couldn't tell.
No pun intended.
Well, I certainly could tell
in that YouTube video
and I couldn't and so nothing
came out with Barbara,
but then literally as
we were getting ready
to record this,
30 seconds before we pressed record,
Jessie was standing
right over here and said,
"I'm smelling it again."
So I think the fact that
if you can smell it,
it's a problem
and I think I'm gonna have to go in again.
You're gonna have to go in deeper.
It's a, you need a deeper pinch.
And don't wear gloves.
You really need to bond with your dog.
What is wrong with you?
Anyway, so that's, you know,
relationships are changing.
Yeah.
Conventions are changing.
I mean, if I can figure out how to do this
are we gonna take...
Our groomer's gonna go out of business.
My groomer's not gonna go out of business
because this isn't something I
want to make a regular thing.
This is something I wanna do
only in times of desperation.
It might be like a Dr.
Pimple Popper thing,
you might experience some pleasure
associated with a victory,
with success.
Don't count your chickens
before the can opens.
You might like it.
Oh gosh.
Okay, we're gonna talk more
about relational dynamics
and I don't think we're gonna talk anymore
about anuses, dogs or otherwise.
But first, we're gonna
talk about these mugs.
Mythical.com is the source
for everything you need
to express your personal mythicality.
I mean, we have occasion--
Could you not use
the term express.
Oh.
Just don't use the term express.
Let's just not use the term express
for the rest of this.
That was totally
sub-conscious.
I feel like we have
When you look at our mugs,
don't think about your anus.
a connection.
You know, we're connecting
through this conversation.
I feel like you're a
part of it even though
you're pretty quiet.
And you'd feel even more a part of it
if you were drinking tea or coffee
or any beverage you want.
It could be like anal grand excletions
for all I care.
You just said "anal grand excletions."
That's a great band name.
That's how Lock used to talk
when he was a toddler.
Ain't no grand excletions.
Excletions, he would change
words like that, right?
Yeah, still does
from time to time.
Mythical.com.
Yeah, get your mugs.
Connect with us,
make it a complete embodiment experience.
Wear the shirts, wear the necklaces,
wear the perfumes, wear everything we sell
and then sip from the things we sell.
Okay, before we dive into this,
I will say we're gonna
be talking about this
from the standpoint of
people who are in a family
and trapped with them.
And I know that there are
a lot of single people
who have maybe the opposite problem,
which is no one to connect with
and so there's, I think
there's a loneliness.
That's not something that
we can speak to personally
at this point.
But I do wanna recognize
there are a lot of people
in that particular situation.
I'm glad you're bringing that up.
Yeah because I think there's
gonna be some complaining
coming from us.
And I don't know, maybe if
you're in a different situation,
maybe it'll be helpful for them to hear
about how it's not that great
for us at times, either.
But it is a good acknowledgement and
we feel for you if you
feel isolated or lonely
and we wanna encourage you to do
whatever you can to break out of that.
And I know I can imagine that
might be difficult at times
to pick up the video chat into initiate.
I don't know, it may be more for guys
to say, "Hey, I'm just Facetiming you
"because I feel lonely."
It's not the type of thing that
what I didn't feel like that was a thing
as a guy, that I would give
myself permission to say
years back.
Yeah.
Good acknowledgement.
So I found a couple of articles
that I think speak to this.
One of the thing's that's
happening of course
is couples who have never
spent this much time together
are now spending this much time together
and the question is
what is that going to do
for relationships?
What is that doing for families?
I mean when you think about our situation,
which I think is probably
a pretty typical situation
in the world and in America
is that a lot of dads
are spending a lot more time at home
than they normally would.
And this isn't just dads, its--
Working mom's.
Yeah, working mom's.
Anybody who has spent a
lot of time traditionally
outside of the house is suddenly there
and it's like one of those,
if you think about when you go on vacation
and we've talked about
this dynamic before.
When you go on vacation,
even with the distractions
of vacation, being in a
foreign land of some kind...
Yeah.
Having a schedule, having a pool
that you could lounge next
to and stuff like that,
even with all those amenities,
still by the end of a week long vacation,
most people are like, "I gotta get away
"from my family."
You know?
Yeah.
But we're all on extended vacations
of indefinite length and we don't have,
we actually have the most
familiar surroundings
and we don't have an option
to really experience,
most of our neighborhoods are becoming
much more familiar, I mean, I have walked,
I could draw you a map of my neighborhood
at this point.
That doesn't actually
sound impressive, but okay.
You couldn't draw a map of
your neighborhood before this?
Okay, that's fine.
That's, no judgment.
No, I mean have you been,
my neighborhood's got
a lot of weird streets
and there's no system.
There's not a grid.
And so I'm just saying now I feel I...
I've been on streets that
are less than a mile away
that was like, "Never been on this street,
"never been on this street."
I've been on all the
streets now, multiple times.
But I'm just saying that
the level of familiarity
with our family and our surroundings is at
an all time high.
Oh yeah.
And it's creating some different dynamics.
There was an article in the...
Well, I've seen a few articles that talk
about what's gonna happen?
Is there gonna be a Coronavirus baby boom?
Because all of these
couple are at home together
and everybody's having sex,
like, "Ooh ah, it's just
"a sex party all the time."
I know how babies are made.
And then the other theory is
well actually there's gonna
be a boom in divorces.
I think most likely you're
gonna see both of those things
happening, hopefully
not in the same families
together at the same time.
Hopefully they're happening
in separate families.
I think there was the
honeymoon phase of quarantine
that was like, "Hey, let's sort the mail,
"this'll be fun."
Right.
And then a few weeks later it's like,
"What are you?
"We don't have any mail!"
I checked the mailbox!
And I walked straight from the mailbox
to the recycle bin because everything
that was sent was junk!
For those of you who may be confused
or you're maybe you're a new listener
to Ear Biscuits...
We can have inside jokes.
Don't explain it.
I have to explain it because
I care about those people.
Sorting the mail is a
euphemism, only on this podcast
for sexual intercourse.
I know how babies are made.
Don't ask us how that
happened, but it did.
It involved getting locked
I'm gonna review
from an article...
in my bedroom, ironically.
This is an article in the New York Post,
which is not typically a publication
that I frequent,
but they had an article
about the surge in divorces.
Copped up New Yorkers are
flooding lawyer phone lines
with divorce inquiries,
with an avalanche of filings expected
once the courts reopen.
"People are realizing that
they can't stand each other,"
said Manhattan lawyer,
Suzanne Kimberly Bracker,
who like many in her
field has already seen
a Coronavirus divorce uptick.
In the middle of the night,
I got a call from a
client who now realizes
she has nothing in
common with her husband,
but the children, and how he knows nothing
about the children.
So, it's like...
And this is something that
again, this is sort of
a stereotypical tropy thing,
but you've got the dude
who's been off at his job
and then he comes back
home and he is like,
"Oh, now I've got to engage with the kids
"more than just like hey, I'm home,
"Dad's home, let's shoot some basketball
"for 30 minutes and that
makes me a great dad."
But you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Now you're expected,
and a lot of people are
continuing to do their jobs
from home, which can be
a little bit disruptive.
I mean, even right now, we're sitting here
in the middle of our homes
making everybody else be relatively quiet
while we do this.
Yeah, typically Lily will roll out of bed
and she'll walk in here
and she'll see me doing this
and then she will just
slump over, roll her eyes,
and go back into her bedroom
because she realizes
she can't make breakfast
because it makes too much noise.
And I told her she could
tiptoe around and make
the breakfast, but you know what?
She's being ultrasensitive.
I mean, not sensitive, but considerate
and she's not doing it.
But it's like yeah, so
our work lives coming home
is a severe inconvenience to our families.
You're in the freaking
middle of your living room.
If somebody wanted to
watch TV this morning,
that ain't happening--
There's other televisions.
Well, it wouldn't be on
the big one on your left.
Exactly.
Yeah and one of the things
that's happening too
is I think that a lot of people are seeing
their working parent
or their working spouse
in work mode in a way that they haven't.
This is in an article
from the Washington Post.
This woman, Laura Norkin,
Deputy Editor of In-Style Magazine,
tweeted the funny thing about quarantining
is hearing your partner in full work mode
for the first time.
Mm, mm hmm.
Like I'm married to a let's
circle back guy, who knew?
It's like let's circle back.
It's like I've never heard
somebody use that.
We can take this offline.
And then circle back on it later
and then we can close the loop
when we've taken the pin out of it,
but for now we're putting the pin in it.
Put a pin in it.
Now I will say there are
some positives from this,
so as you know we have
our company wide meeting
and there's not really a
place in my house to get away
even when you go into the
most private of places,
which would be our little guest bedroom.
The crack under the door is like an inch,
so you can hear everything
that's happening in there.
And Jessie was working
outside on her computer
right outside the room
and we had our meeting,
we have it every two weeks
where everybody in Mythical
gets on a video chat and
we talk about business
and also just connect with one another.
And I come out of the
door and she was like,
"You sound like a good boss."
That's nice.
You sound like a good boss.
She's like, "You sound
like a nice, nice boss."
Was she surprised?
And I was like, "Oh, thank you."
I think that she knows that I'm not,
neither of us are those typical
chew your head off bosses,
that's just not in our
character, disposition.
But I think listening in on the meeting
and again just hearing my side of it.
So I didn't come out and she said,
"Oh, you're a circle back guy,"
she said, "Oh, you're a nice boss."
I was like, "Well, good, yeah."
I'm gonna get a mug that
says I'm a nice boss.
As I'm setting things up
for Good Mythical Morning
or for this show, I
notice Christy was home,
she'll like look at me
and like she's assessing me.
Even just right before we start recording,
she comes right over the camera,
she pokes her head
around from the kitchen.
She's like, "Are you okay?"
Now that's a loaded question.
There's a little more to it
that I could get into it a little bit,
but I'm like, "I'm fine."
She's like, "You look pale."
I'm like, what I'm thinking is,
I get stressed out right
before I do something,
especially when there's all these people
and groceries came in this morning again,
oh, good Lord.
Oh yeah, that'll throw you off.
Don't get me going.
I'm like yeah I'm pale.
I get pale before I start anything
because I'm frigging stress spiking
and then I get my robe on and I sit down
and I'm like,
"All right, all right."
And then I mellow out a little bit
and then I get in the zone.
The auto zone.
But she's like,
"You are so worked up."
Not a sponsor.
I'm like, "Yeah, I get worked up."
That's why it's called work.
I get up for it.
So I didn't get it.
You're a good boss, but she's
not listening in on our--
Oh, I've gotten other things too.
In on our "all hands" meeting
as we used to call it at IBM.
Now before we,
before this takes a trip to the dark side,
I'm gonna talk about
a lot of the positives
because I think that this has
been a really positive time
for our family in a lot of ways,
I made a little list here,
so I wouldn't forget.
Now Jessie and I had a date night before
where we would go out once a week,
but we're continuing to do that.
Date night is our takeout night
where we get some takeout
and send the children away.
They can be anywhere,
but anywhere near us.
And we put on some music, change
the lighting a little bit.
Still in the kitchen, I'm not talking
about the bedroom yet.
Okay,
that's where it begins.
Where the sorting of mail
is happening,
and we just have a nice dinner and we talk
about the nature of our relationship,
we actually talk about how we talk.
I think that's been good.
We got our family movie night that we do
every Friday night where
we all sit down and try
to agree on a movie, which
has been going pretty well.
Really?
Watched Tombstone the other night,
that was a hit.
Mm hmm.
Val Kilmer's performance,
Not on your list, but...
One of the best ever.
Kurt Russell, a little
uneven acting in that movie,
but he's Kurt Russell.
We're also like you,
we're watching Survivor,
that's something the
family is connected on.
Lock and I have our horror movie night
on Saturday nights.
Shepard and I are starting
an art project based
on the golden ratio, Fibonacci numbers,
and we are playing HORSE
and having putting contests,
there's a lot of family
interaction that's happening
at a higher volume that has been great,
but of course, with all that interaction
with the good comes the bad.
Yeah, we've had...
I mean, you know how the Neal's are,
they like to stay hydrated
and when we go in on something,
we go in deep, we go in hard.
Boy, that sounded weird.
We fully commit to something.
And there's a dark side to that.
We started watching Survivor
and as we discussed before,
we started at season 17
because I knew that if everyone got hooked
on it and we got aligned on this thing,
we needed a whole bunch of seasons
to just start binging through
because we wouldn't want,
we just wanna keep going
down that rabbit hole.
So now we're over
halfway through season 18
and everybody's so excited about it,
it aligns us,
it's a beautiful thing.
It's kinda magical.
Everyone loves it.
Lately, it's the only
thing we've been willing
to do together, like there's...
So here I am already
going to the dark side.
I mean, yesterday, I'm filming,
we're doing an AMA for
the Mythical Society peeps
and I guess to them it
just looks like I'm typing
on my computer, I'm not filming anything,
and they're outside in the
garage playing ping pong,
which that's another thing that we do,
but now that's become
a source of contention.
I didn't finish the Survivor thought.
The thought is, Survivor's
the only thing that
we end up doing every single night,
so we don't have enough variety
and it's like--
You're watching Survivor every night?
Every single night
and it's too much.
It's a problem.
Yeah.
And then we're not having
enough other positive outlets
as a family, so I'm doing the AMA and
their outside playing ping pong and then,
this is not the first nor the second time
this has happened in the past three days,
but all of the sudden,
I hear Lando screaming.
And a lot of times when he's screaming,
he's screaming, "Delete it!
"Delete it!."
What?
"Delete it!"
And he comes in here and he
runs to me and he's like,
"Dad, Lincoln took video of
me and he won't delete it."
I'm like, "What's he gonna do?
"Is he gonna post it online?"
He's like, "He might."
I was like, "Has he ever done that?"
Then Lincoln walks in and
he has this Lincoln grin
on his face.
He thinks...
He is enjoying this moment.
This is what he's doing it for.
Yeah.
He's a big brother.
To drive him crazy.
You would of thought that
Lincoln filmed Lando confessing
to a murder.
It's like that's the level of intensity.
And then the more that
Lincoln just grins at him,
the more he just goes ballistic.
And I get to a point where I'm like...
And then three hours later, I'm queuing
up Survivor, okay, finally we can have
our positive time together.
We can agree on this,
we can at least be in the same room,
but not at each other's throats.
And I'm like, they wouldn't
come and they wouldn't come,
so I've got this technique
where I start playing Survivor
really loud.
And then they'll stop
what they're doing and
they'll all run in, they'll
get off their phones
or whatever and run in.
Well this time, instead of that happening,
it was, "Delete it!
"Delete it!"
And they ran in and you know what?
Without thinking about it,
I was like, "I don't wanna hear it!
"You two go back out of
the room and handle it!"
And then they stood there,
kinda like bumfuzzled,
and I was like, "Go out of the room
"and handle it!"
And I looked at Christy,
who I was talking with
before they came in and
she was like, she had
this disappointed look
on her face
at me.
Yeah, yeah.
And then the boys left and I'm like,
"What were you saying?"
It's like at a certain point
the button's been pushed so much
that it won't pop back up.
You know that?
You know that type of button?
Where it gets pushed in
and then it gets lodged
underneath something, so it's like...
Or you think that the
button popped back up,
but really like you push it and
instead of it popping back up,
you push it and then you watch it,
I don't think the button...
And then all of the sudden it starts
to come back up a little
bit and then stops.
That happens with literally
every keyboard that
we put in our kitchen...
Jelly.
Because no matter how
many times I tell my kids
to wash their hands before they type,
they don't, they won't.
So we go through one magic Apple keyboard
every seven months.
You talk about being a good boss?
It's part of my budget.
And the way that we talk to our employees,
sometimes it gets familial.
There's a good level of family atmosphere
and team atmosphere,
but if I talk...
Man, I'm just being honest.
You'd be shocked if you saw
some of the things that I exude,
especially in this time-.
Well, okay.
And to support you in this
I've already said
that I've squeezed my kids,
but that was a joke.
Well, but in terms of the
losing it and yelling...
And first of all there's
people who are in families
where that doesn't ever happen.
Right.
And it's great for you.
And also you might be
shocked when you hear,
"Oh, you guys yell at your children?"
'Cuz I know, I know that
my kids have friends
whose parents never yell at them
and that's just not our family.
I'm not proud of it,
it's just the way we are.
And like Jessie will be
working with Shepard,
getting him to do...
Now again, she's homeschooled
the kids for forever
and they've only been in
school for three years now,
but of course she thought she was done
and now everybody's homeschooling, right?
And they're doing the
distance learning thing, but
with Shepard, especially,
that doesn't mean that he's
just gonna do the work.
You've gotta stay with him
and make him do the work,
keep him from being distracted.
And Jessie is more
patient than me and tries
to engage with him in a fruitful way,
in an effective way.
Yeah, we both married
much better people than we are.
And that's a wonderful thing for us.
And then she will...
But then I'll come out
of a meeting or podcast,
or whatever I happen to be doing and
she'll say, "Your turn."
And this is not something
that happens when I'm at work,
but when I'm at home
working, it does happen
on a regular basis.
And then I'll go in there and I'll enter
into the situation with Shepard
with some patience at the beginning
that is exhausted...
I think my patience tank
needs to be repaired,
it has several leaks.
And as soon as I fill it
up, Shepard finds a way
to pull the plugs out
and basically I've gone
from trying to work
with him to just telling him...
Just basically shaming him.
That's ultimately what
yelling at somebody does.
You're trying to use shame
to get them to do it.
And I know it's not effective.
When I'm doing it, I
know it's not effective,
but that's what I end up resorting to
very quickly--
In my mind...
And your tank gets smaller
and smaller and smaller
the more time that you spend together.
In my mind I'm thinking and I did once
I did tell Christy at that point,
I was like, I figured
this was worth a shot.
After I said, "Just resolve it yourself,
"handle it!."
And they left the room and I was like
"What were we talking about?"
The I was like I yelled
in a calculated way
because I want
'cuz we don't yell that often.
I mean it's not something,
I mean there are
family cultures where little
subcultures of families
where they yell more and it's
just like everybody's got
a thick skin when it
comes to that and it's
a form of communication, everybody knows
how to handle it and I
don't think it's absolutely
a horrible thing to raise your voice.
I would imagine that there's home climates
where it can just be,
you can be expressive,
but it very quickly
goes into a danger zone
and that's what we feel
in our house and so
the goal is to always
remain in control and not
to raise your voice.
I mean, we all agree on that over here.
And that's...
I wouldn't put that
standard on anybody else
'cuz I'm not a psychologist,
but for me, that's where we've landed.
So it does make me feel like a failure
when I do yell,
but I thought it was worth a shot
for me to say, "This
is a calculated yell,"
for me to express how
much of an impact this
ongoing quarrel has on me.
It's like, "Oh, dad must
feel strongly about this.
"This is impacting him."
Yeah.
I mean, it wasn't that
compelling of an argument,
but I tried.
Did it work?
No, it wasn't that Christy was mad at me.
I mean, we just, she
helped me talk through it
and then I was like--
No, did they resolve their
conflict and come back in?
Yeah, well, I didn't hear it anymore.
They shut up.
Which again, that was my goal.
It was like stop impacting
my quality of life.
It was that selfish
stance of I don't care,
as long as you guys can
shut up somewhere else
and I don't hear it, I will be fine.
But then later on we called
them back in there and
we had a 10 minute discussion
that was more like,
"Hey, how do we get to
the bottom of this?"
Now, in retrospect, I might,
could've added an apology
about losing my cool and raising my voice,
especially when you make
the point about shaming
because I think that's a good point.
Maybe I'll revisit that.
But we at least had a
constructive conversation
about how they can own
what they're doing and
what their motives are and...
'Cuz Lincoln's doing it on purpose
and now Lando's developing
this coping mechanism
of yelling at him, and
this is a new thing.
So it's like trying to
get to the bottom of that.
But I mean and this came
at the end of a long day.
I mean, at the beginning of the day,
in a different way than Shepard,
but we're having, we're
just trying to get Lincoln
to be more motivated to do his schoolwork.
It's very difficult to do schoolwork
in this environment and
he comes in this morning
and he's like, "Mom, dad,
I've done some research."
And I'm like, I perk up,
I'm like my boy's done research.
This is great.
I immediately felt proud.
I was like I've never heard
him use that phrase before.
I've done some research.
And he says, "The LA
Unified School District
"says that the grades
that you had when you left
"for quarantine, they
can't make your grade lower
"than that, so I'm not gonna
do anymore schoolwork."
I was like well this took a turn.
And then Christy was
like, "Who told you this?"
Yeah, that's some high school rumor, man.
Well my friends aren't doing their work
'cuz they said that's true.
And she's like first of all,
we're not in the LA
Unified School District,
so you need to do more research.
And so we on and off all day
we were bantering, getting into that
and then Lando and him are
at each other's throats
because I won't let them
be on screens all day
and I force them to go
outside and play together
and then they come in
at each other's throats.
And Lily had her own...
I'm not gonna tell Lily's story on here,
but it was something that,
Lily suffered a disappointment,
like she got some disappointing news,
something she was looking forward to,
it went the other way.
And this was like months
of looking forward
to getting this news.
And so it was a bit shattering
for Christy and I, as well as for her.
So it's like that was also yesterday.
You have these ideas that things are...
And on previous podcasts
we talk about this mindset
of seeing things as an opportunity
and not being Pollyanna
about how things are going
in the world or even in our homes,
but feeling like, okay, you know what?
We can find the silver lining,
we can see the opportunities in this,
we can like the things
that you listed out.
And then knowing at the end of this
that we're going to see
it as a precious time
because we do love each
other and thank goodness
we care about each other and we're not...
There's a lot of people
who a) don't have anybody
or they're on the outs of a relationship
or they were about to break up.
There's lots of more nightmare situations
than the ones we're in.
We've got it really
great with our families.
But it just gets to you, man.
Well and I think that it's,
I mean, I do think that it's important
to recognize that because I'm
sure you could say something,
and I'm sure someone has
written something like this
where it's like it's
not that being cooped up
in your home is going to cause a divorce,
it's that being cooped
up in your home is going
to reveal the reality of whether or not
you actually connect.
That's the kind of BS
that somebody would say
because the fact is is that
regardless of the nature
of your relationship,
regardless of how healthy it is,
this is going to be
difficult for almost everyone
and that doesn't mean
that you should break up
or you should get a divorce,
or you're not compatible.
Now, that also doesn't mean that
there will be some real
discovery and real discussion
during this time that you
realize you got some things
to work on or maybe you do realize that
you've come to an impasse
that you can't get through,
but I think it's helpful that you're,
that it's incredibly normal to respond
to this situation in a negative way
and have to resist being selfish
and being self interested,
and also think there is some,
depending on your personality,
I mean, for me, as an introvert, it's like
it's not a negative thing
when I think, "I gotta get
away from these people."
That doesn't make me a bad person,
it doesn't make them bad people,
it just means that the Rhett-ster needs
to ejector himself from this situation
Right.
And go on a solo walk.
In fact, Jessie and I were
talking about this yesterday
because Jessie is a...
One of the biggest differences
between the two of us,
we have so many things in common,
we enjoy so many things,
we connect in a lot of different ways,
but she is a hyper-extrovert
and I'm not a hyper-introvert,
I present as an extrovert to most people
who get to know me for the first time,
but in reality I'm
energized by being alone,
so I'm an introvert.
But, so when I talk about things like I'm
gonna go work out.
The first week she was like,
"You wanna work out together?"
And I'm like, "No!
"I don't wanna work out together."
For like seven reasons,
the least of which being
that we're not gonna do the same stuff
in the workout, but the main reason being
that it's a time for me.
I put on, I listen to a book.
I don't listen to pump
up music when I work out,
I listen to books on tape
and when I walk around the
neighborhood by myself,
today, I listen as well,
but it's like--
You got a Walkman?
A cassette tape?
No, I just have, I've just
got earphones and an iPhone.
Yeah it's your time and
you need that recharging.
And I need it.
Even today or yesterday when...
Our days right now
consist of doing something
in the morning and
something in the afternoon
that's work related typically, right,
every weekday?
And even something as simple as like,
okay, let's record two episodes
of Good Mythical Morning today.
Like there's been some days
where we've recorded one
in the morning and one in the evening,
or one in the afternoon
and you would think
oh, two episodes of GMM, that's,
well what else have you got going on?
That's an easy day.
But the setup and then
the getting it all right
and then the meeting
before and the doing it
and then the taking the thumbnails
and then uploading the footage...
Before you know it you've taken all day
to shoot two episodes of GMM.
And that is not me time.
Right, exactly,
but I had a little window in between
the other day and I said,
"I'm gonna take a walk by myself."
It was sunny outside.
I was like, "I'm gonna
take a walk by myself."
And then Jessie said, "Okay."
And then she told me this morning,
"When you said that,"
because we were talking about this dynamic
before we recorded this,
she said, "You know, my instinct is
"is to be like I wanna
go on a walk with you."
Like, "If you're gonna go on a walk
"let's go together."
But then she's like, "No,
I stopped and realized
"that no, that's what he needs,
"that's good for him."
And it's not saying anything about me.
Like she was like that's not
saying anything about her
that I need to get away from her,
it's saying more about me.
Yeah, it reminds me of the same principle,
but Christy made a comment to me
at the end of the night last night,
after we had gotten through Survivor
and then I think there was,
there was still...
I said something sarcastic
while everyone was going
off to bed and she said,
"You know what, I think the only person
"that doesn't annoy you is you."
And then she turned to the whole family
she's like, "You know
what, I think your dad
"might need to camp in the backyard,
"he might need to do a little camping time
"by himself."
And I'm like, all right, first of all,
all right tit for tat,
I was sarcastic, so message received
and I laughed and it broke the tension.
It didn't escalate it, de-escalate,
she was doing that to
de-escalate and it worked.
But yeah, I think that
was her observation,
we're coming to grips with that too
that I've been getting up an hour
or an hour and a half
before everybody else
and I've been meditating.
Today was 30 days in a row I've meditated.
Wow.
Yeah, so it's like,
it keeps a record of it on the app,
so it motivates me to do it, like I said.
I don't know, it's not enough.
I don't know,
it's like I still suck
at meditating by the way,
so I'm not bragging.
It's just like I am
getting insights, but...
Insights into myself and how to cope,
but I'm not quite engaging
those lessons enough,
but the other thing I
haven't mentioned yet
as far as relating to Christy goes,
I think it's been a real
challenge and you know this,
that Christy's been
sick for over two weeks.
And it was a mild fever
everyday for the past
over two weeks that hasn't broken 100,
but when it's like that
for days and days and days,
and weeks, she's been in
conversation with her doctor
and there's been stomach issues,
so loss of appetite.
So she's lost over 10 pounds
because she hasn't been able to eat
with diarrhea.
But those are the only symptoms,
so the doctor was saying well that's,
COVID was weird and it
manifests in different ways
in different people,
but they didn't think that's what it was,
but then finally after a week and a half,
I took her to get the test,
like a drive though test
and I gotta say, I got a thrill
out of her taking the test
because it's like a pipe cleaner,
it's like a freaking pipe cleaner
that's like that long.
And they said you'll drive up
and you can stay in your car
and we'll do the throat swab
and so Christy was thinking
it was a throat swab,
but the way that they access
the throat is through the nose.
Oh gosh.
And so I knew this,
she didn't know it, so...
and I didn't know for
sure she didn't know it
until I saw the look on her face
as it started to happen.
The dude reaches in,
he's like, "Now I'm gonna
"count five seconds.
"It's gonna feel a lot
longer than five seconds,
"but I'm just gonna count."
And then the guy took the pipe cleaner,
put it in her nose.
Her eyes got huge, her feet started
beating the floor board of the car
and she said that it went all the,
she said, "If I would have opened my mouth
"and looked at you,
"you would've seen the
thing go past my throat,
"down there and start..."
And then he's counting to
five and he's twisting it.
Yeah.
And then he's pulling it out and...
I'm sorry, I got a kick out
of her being so surprised
not because it hurt because it was,
I wouldn't say it hurt,
it did hurt, but it
was more uncomfortable.
It's like when...
You've experienced it,
we've both experienced it
because when we went
to the plastic surgeon
to do the commercial and he showed you
how to look down at your throat,
well they did the same thing to me
at EMT when I was having
some throat issues
a couple years ago.
And again, it goes through the nose.
And I have a deviated
septum and my right nostril
you can't get in there
and the left nostril is
open, but prone to bleeding,
so I just, I don't wanna
have to get tested.
I hope they come out with...
I want one of the less invasive ones.
Two days later we got the results back,
they were negative.
She was still having the symptoms and
I mean, she started to
develop pain in her chest,
like it was like I think
I'm having trouble breathing
and I was...
She had had that similar
symptom earlier in the year
and she got checked out for that
and we thought it might be
a heart thing or something.
She got all checked out and she was fine.
We realized that anxiety was driving
a lot of her symptoms at the time
and then I was making
the point that those,
I think anxiety might be
manifesting this symptom now
because even though
your test was negative,
the doctor did happen to
mention that it's possible
to have a false negative.
That she could have COVID, but that...
And they said if you start
to have breathing problems,
you need to call us and then we might need
to take decisive action.
And then I observed that she started to
say that she was having
breathing problems.
She woke up in the middle of the night.
I woke up three nights ago
at like 3:30 in the
morning and she was having
a panic attack,
but she didn't know if
she just couldn't breathe.
And it was, I don't, I mean
I was kinda groggy,
I'm not the most supportive at 4 AM,
I was trying to be supportive,
but I mean ultimately yesterday
she went in for a lung x-ray
just so the doctor could
make sure she didn't have it.
We didn't go to the
emergency room that night,
I kinda talked her down
and helped her calm down.
But then the next morning, which
was yesterday, she went in.
The test results for
that were totally clear,
her lungs are totally fine,
which is more support that this is,
I don't know if I would say psychosomatic,
maybe that is the right term,
but it's caused by her heightened anxiety
associated with being in this pandemic
where, here's the connection for her,
over three years ago and
she's told this story
on Science Mike's podcast
about how she hit her head,
she had the concussion,
she still suffers from
post-concussion syndrome,
but the thing that I think
we're coming to grips with
is that because of that
she's suffering from PTSD.
She now on a sub-conscious level,
believes that if something so,
if the odds are so low
for her hitting her head
on a limb walking into the Trader Joe's
can then three years later have a dramatic
and drastic impact on her life,
then well when this virus
starts sweeping through town,
she's gonna get it.
She just knows it.
That's the survival technique
that I think she's learned.
So it's been difficult.
With a couple of days of
a flare up of symptoms
and anxiety, we can work together,
but when it's over two weeks,
it starts to become very difficult
to be empathetic.
'Cuz it's frustrating.
It's really frustrating for
me because I feel like I
don't have the magic words
to get through to her
or I don't have the techniques to fix her.
And she's not asking for that from me.
She's asking for an open ear
and she's asking for I
think she wants empathy
and she just wants me to be there for her
as she goes through this and be supportive
because she does have a therapist,
she does have a brain doctor,
she does have a normal doctor,
and she has other friends that provide
a support structure too,
so it's like she doesn't
need everything from me,
I don't need to be the silver bullet,
but everyday it gets
increasingly more difficult,
especially when I see that her
symptoms are getting better
except for the anxiety.
So it's...
And she gave me permission to
talk about this by the way.
She's like, "What are you gonna
talk about on Ear Biscuits?"
And I was like, "We're gonna
talk about relational dynamics.
She's like, "You can talk
about this because..."
And I applaud her for it that the things
that I'm sharing are not
things to be embarrassed about,
they're actual conditions
that people suffer from.
Whether it's depression, anxiety,
post-concussion syndrome,
all types of silent illnesses,
I think she encouraged
me to share this story
because just to remove that stigma,
but you know--
And I can speak on behalf of
hypochondriacs everywhere,
which I think people who would relate to
and I talked to my dad who,
my dad is like me and presents
himself as invincible,
but it's like okay, the very first...
So I went a long time in my life
without thinking that, not believing,
like I'd refuse to believe
that you could feel something
physical, in your body and it not be real.
Like, but in the past 10 years,
I have felt so many specific things;
injuries, and sicknesses,
and then it turns out not
to be anything and it's
because and so with Coronavirus,
the first week that we were home,
I swear to you, 'cuz I was
consuming so much news,
I had pain, legitimate pain in my chest.
And I kep telling Jessie,
I'm like, "I think I've got it."
I was like I don't have
any other symptoms,
but like when I breathe in
it hurt, my chest hurts.
I was like literally I can point to it,
it's hurting right here
and it's hurting right here
and I was like and it comes and it goes
and I've had it for a week.
And then I talked to
my dad and he was like,
"I've had Coronavirus 20 times
"since this whole thing started,"
He was like it's just in our genes
for it to manifest itself in that way,
so I mean, it doesn't mean you're crazy,
I think it's very normal
and you can actually...
And I've had a couple panic attacks.
I'm not crazy.
You're saying it doesn't
mean that my wife is crazy?
Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a couple of like
and that whole feeling like
you can't breathe thing and like
a couple of times in the past few weeks
I've woken up in the middle of the night
and I've been like,
"I think I'm not getting a full breath."
And the moment that you think that,
it's very difficult to get out of it,
it's very difficult to get out of it.
And again, I'm not telling
people that they should
ignore their symptoms,
I do think that for me a lot
of times doing what Christy did
and like going and getting the x-ray so
you can be told, definitively,
sometimes you do need that, you need that.
Like oh no, there's actually
nothing wrong with you
because hypochondriacs
like me will keep thinking,
"Yeah, you're just telling
me there's nothing wrong
"with me, but in reality there is,
"and you just don't want
me to think about it.
And sometimes you do
have to go to that place.
It can get to a place where you're having
to have all these things
confirmed all the time,
but I just say that
as somebody who hasn't
had nearly the issue,
the struggle that Christy has had
and I haven't had the
post-concussion syndrome
or anything like that,
but I am a hypochondriac
and I have thought
that I had Coronavirus
already and I was sure of it.
It's just so difficult to be empathetic
because I'm not great at it in general,
but then, and I think when we were talking
about our highlights from the year,
I might've talked about the dynamic of,
I end up...
I'm not sure, but
whenever she says I'm
concerned about this,
whether it's physical
symptoms related to this
or it's related to the
kids or something else,
whenever she expresses
anxiety towards something
my knee jerk reaction,
without actually hearing her
is to just minimize or try to
make it disappear entirely,
like to dismiss her instincts
or her concerns.
And I told her it's
like at a certain point
if something's really concerning,
she'll be like, "You don't
seem concerned at all."
One time I was like, "If
you cry wolf too many times
"then the farmer's not gonna come,"
or I don't know how the story goes.
And that was not a sensitive thing to say,
but it was an honest thing.
That like it's a struggle
to continue to hear her
and to empathize with
her when it's so foreign
to my own experience that I think
I live with my head in the
clouds sometimes maybe.
Is I think how she feels about me
because our experience is
so different in this way
and it's, so it's...
But it's very frustrated
to not be able to fix it
and then whenever I start
to say well that's not
what I need to do, I
just need to be there,
then it's hard to access the energy to
because it's against my instincts
to interact with her in that way.
So after over two weeks of that,
again, that was the last
thing of the past two days
that was like okay, this is difficult.
Just to close the loop on it,
what was the corporate saying?
Circle back.
I don't wanna have to
circle back on this later,
so let's close the loop now.
This morning, I took my meditative time
to think more about her and about just
to have an exercise in empathy
and then afterward, it
gave me the capacity
to go upstairs and to apologize for
how I wore my frustration on my sleeve
and there was no yelling with Christy,
it wasn't like that.
It was more of like a just you
could sense the frustration
and it seemed like annoyance.
But I think we've had a good
conversation this morning
and clear the air about that
and I know that she is
pulling on resources
and seeing ways that she can,
there's additional
treatments and therapies
and things like that will
help her through this.
That it's not and I can
be there to help her wade
through that stuff,
but I mean I know she's
in that process too, so we're not stuck
and we're not...
And so we had a moment.
We had a good moment this morning
where it was like a reconnection
and just being honest,
so that's just to close
the loop on that but...
Given the...
There's a lot of things about
this particular situation
and the things that we continue to read
about the virus that make it
a very specifically difficult situation
for people who are hypochondriacs
because the symptoms are,
they don't know anything about it.
It's like you read one
article and it's like
okay, well it seems that
it presents this way
in most people, but and for
some people it's just like this
and some people all the sudden they go...
There's all these little things
that I think people who
write these articles
and again, they're not, you don't,
when you're writing about it,
you don't have hypochondriacs in mind
and actually hypochondriacs need to learn
how to deal with, I say
this as a hypochondriac,
I need to be able to
engage with information
in a way that doesn't
immediately make me think
that I have it.
But it's very difficult
because it manifests itself
in so many different ways
and we've been told it's super contagious
and you're out of your normal routine,
you gotta...
All a lot of us are doing
is just reading the news
and sitting around and thinking.
And it's like that could be
a really bad combination.
So I do think it's important that,
and again, for the longest time
I just thought that my
mom was a hypochondriac
and I was like well that's not me
and then I realized, no, you know what?
Actually, I am.
And now talking to my dad,
oh and also my dad is.
It's like we all have this tendency
to immediately internalize it,
so I just think that it's okay.
It doesn't make you abnormal.
It's such a common thing,
but it is important to
realize it and address it.
I mean, with me, I got a
therapist I can talk to
about it.
I think that that continues
to be really important
for a lot of people.
There are resources, there's
mental health resources
that are available in
this very difficult time
for a lot of people and
we just encourage you
to continue to seek those out.
Not a sponsor.
They were a sponsor at one time,
but I know there's better help,
which is like you basically
can have a teleconference
with somebody, which
is what we're all doing
with our therapists right now anyway,
but there are services like that,
we just encourage you to, if you feel like
you need somebody to talk
to and don't have somebody
that you can talk to,
who will listen and be helpful
and again, like Link's talking about,
it's like none of us
are trained in this and
a lot of times don't know what to say
and will say the wrong thing.
Finding somebody who can
actually help you think
through this and work
through this in a healthy way
is important.
Yeah.
It's helpful to talk about it here.
I think it's, with Christy's permission,
it's calculated to talk about it here
because I know a lot of
people, like you said,
relate to it and yeah.
We're not in the business
of providing answers,
but we're in the business
of just being honest
and sharing our journey,
and it's helpful to me to do that,
so I appreciate opening the can of listen,
it's your wreck.
Yeah, so I'm gonna wreck
a book that I listen to
during my workouts and my strolls.
Okay.
And it's called Underland
by Robert MacFarlane.
And I didn't know about
this Robert MacFarlane guy,
I didn't know he's a writer from the UK
who sort of specializes
in writing about nature.
So it's nonfiction, but
the way that he writes
about his experience,
specifically in Underland,
which I've always been
fascinated with geology
and also just underground
things in general,
but this is this incredible
multiyear journey
where he went underground, basically,
into like caves and mines
and underground systems
under cities and met the people
who know about these places
and visited them himself
and his way of bringing
you along for the ride,
but it also becomes a
story about the earth
and the environment and
what's happening in the world.
Top 10 favorite books of all time.
What and it's not even, it's nonfiction?
Yeah.
And again this isn't for everybody,
but if you happen to be
interested in the way
that I described that, if
that piques your interest
at all, there's nobody that I'm aware of
who can write in a more compelling way.
Almost a spiritual way.
There's like a spiritual experience
in the way that he approaches this stuff
that it's again, it's
been super meditative
to walk and listen to this,
these stories about these people
and it's sort of like really tapped
into my sense of adventure,
which I feel like I haven't been feeding
for a long time.
We do a lot of crazy things,
our lives are pretty...
We could do a lot of amazing things,
but just this guy's commitment
to going out into the world
and then talking about
it in a compelling way.
So that's Underland.
Underland.
Okay.
Yeah, all one word.
All right, thanks for hanging
out with us this week.
We'll speak at you again next week.
You know we love you.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.